the National Transportation Safety Board  is expected to investigate the deadly  crash of a tour helicopter in Hawaii the  Eurocopter as350 went down in a remote  part of the island of kauai on thursday  all seven people on board were killed  so far only the remains of six have been  found on Friday the fire chief said the  weather and the terrain have complicated  search efforts and anyone that is  familiar with the Napali Coast knows  that it can be clear in the morning and  with the trade winds that we do have it  can weather can roll in including bog  fog excuse me just like how it did today  with arson operations as well the search  for the seventh person on the chopper is  expected to resume today this is at  least the ninth crash of a sightseeing  helicopter in Hawaii in the past five  years  you